you made this terrific for Netflix
touring special stand-up special and we
got these stills of the tour and I can
tell it's just an amazing experience oh
yeah yeah yeah I got all your guitar
yeah I get to jam like you're doing I
hear you without the guitar now not much
not much on this on this laughs no no no
not that I toned it down I realized I'll
go with my strengths this time I just
exactly
but then there's this other picture of
you on tour right that scared me
I thought you look like you're out there
they were like just read the from The
Book of the Dead one moment in time that
I kind of looked cool and I said
everyone has to see that yeah I don't
normally look that cool no I do a rap
song in it like a funny rap song and a
phone wallet keys is that right yes yeah
and so my guy took the picture so he
puts it up all the time that's that's
it's not that scary the show it's a lot
I know it's a really fun show just that
one moment of it looks like oh my god
he's there to bring judgement day upon
us